[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
SCOTT HUGHES: OK.
So let's just dive in.
And I'll just quickly recap
where we were last time.
So what I did last
time was, we are now
beginning the
adventure, so to speak,
of looking at how one examines--
how one finds and then studies
the properties of solutions
to the Einstein field equations.
In other words, given
a particular source,
what is the space-time
that emerges?
What is the space-time that
is consistent with that source
of gravity in Einstein's
relativistic theory here?
So we begin-- we're
going to look at this
in a couple of different ways.
And the first one
is where we're going
to-- what we do-- linearize
the Einstein equation.
So we're going to
imagine that space-time
is a small deviation from
the flat space-time that
contains no gravity.
And we are going to expand
the Einstein field equations,
discarding all terms that are
non-linear in the perturbation
away from flat space-time.
So last time we did this, we
developed our field equations,
we recast them in a
form that's particularly
convenient for making
solutions, and we
noted that the coordinate
degrees of freedom
can be thought of as a
kind of gauge freedom
that, in some ways,
it's very useful for us,
because it allows us to write
the equations in a form that
is particularly
amenable to solving,
but can also be a
little bit dangerous,
because you can
sometimes wind up
with a solution whose
physical character is masked
by the nature of that gauge.
I went through a
somewhat advanced topic
for the purposes of
8.962, and I do not
expect students to
follow this in detail.
But it's good to at least
survey this and understand
what was going on with this.
What I did was I decomposed the
perturbation to flat space-time
into irreducible
degrees of freedom.
I sort of chose a
time coordinate.
I then imagined the other
three coordinates in our space,
and I looked at how,
having chosen time,
the different degrees
of freedom decompose
in two scalars with respect
to coordinate rotations,
vectors with respect to
coordinate rotations,
and two-index
tensors with respect
to coordinate rotations.
I then took those, particularly
the vectors and the tensors,
and I further broke them up
into degrees of freedom that
are either divergence-free
vector fields or the gradients
of scalar fields.
And in doing this,
what we found was
that the 10 degrees of freedom
that are specified-- excuse me,
the 10 degrees of freedom that
are present in the perturbation
the space time,
can be broken down
into six functions that are
gauge-invariant plus four gauge
degrees of freedom.
Applying a similar
decomposition to the source,
we found that those six gauge
invariant degrees of freedom
are governed by four
Poisson type equations.
And I will refer you
to the previous lecture
for exact definitions
of these things,
but there is a
scalar field phi that
is related to the mean density
of energy in your space-time
and pressures in your
space-time-- sort
of isotropic stresses.
This DTS is an additional
degree of freedom
that is defined in
that previous lecture.
You find that a Poisson
equation for a scalar
field I called theta is directly
related to the energy density.
There are two degrees
of freedom associated
with sort of off diagonal terms
in the metric-- the time-space
terms in the metric.
And they are related
to the momentum flow.
These are only two
degrees of freedom,
because the psi is a
divergence-free field.
And finally, what
we found is if you
take the spatial piece
of the space-time metric,
you project out
the bits that are
transverse-- in other
words, it's divergence-free.
We will come to a more physical
meaning of this a little bit
later in today's lecture.
And you require that
this be traceless--
then those components of the
spatial space-time perturbation
are already gauge
invariant, and they're
related to sort of anisotropic
stresses in our source.
They are governed
by a wave equation.
And as such, these represent
a radiative degree of freedom.
Because this is
[coughs] (excuse me!)--
because this is trace-free
and divergence-right,
naively you would think that
this has six numbers in it.
A symmetric 3 by 3 matrix is
how you would represent it.
But because it is trace-free and
because it is divergenceless,
there are four constraints.
And so those six independent
numbers are reduced to two.
And as we'll see
in this lecture,
those two degrees of freedom
correspond to the polarizations
of gravitational waves.
Today's lecture is all about
understanding these guys.
Given our kind of funny
schedule that we're on today,
I got up early and have not
had time to take a shower,
so I am wearing my LIGO hat.
And what we're going
to be doing today
is the foundations of
how one calculates this
and why one builds an
observatory like LIGO
to measure these things.
All right.
So let me just write that out.
So our goal for today--
I should say our goal
for this lecture,
because this is the
first of three lectures
I'm going to record today.
Our goal is to understand
hij TT in terms of quantities
that we can observe
and also to understand
how to compute this field--
this hij TT given us source.
So let's begin by just assuming.
Let's begin by focusing
on how we can understand
what hij TT actually means--
how we can go and measure this.
So what I'm going to do
is just we'll start out
by let's just hand
ourselves an hij TT
and study its properties.
So what I'm going to do is begin
with a space-time perturbation
that has everything
except hij TT equal to 0.
So this is something that has
phi equals 0, theta equals 0,
psi equal to 0.
I am going to pick hij TT.
If we have a form such
that it only depends--
it's a function
that depends only
on the combination T minus z.
So this represents
something propagating--
as we see, it actually
describes radiation.
in the z-direction.
So this assumed form
can be represented
by the following matrix.
So if you take a
look at this, I'm
going to justify a few
details of this later.
There's a few constraints.
So it looks like I
have four numbers here.
Because my space-time metric
is always symmetric under--
we'll just say symmetry--
under exchange of indices, h
xy is the same thing as h yx.
So these two things
are the same.
And from the requirement
that this construction be
trace-free--
so from the way I've
written this here,
that tells me that h xx
plus hyy h yy must equal 0.
So these two quantities on the
diagonal are not independent.
They must be of opposite sign.
So there are my two
degrees of freedom.
Why have I set the
z part equal to 0?
We'll look at that in a little
bit more detail a little later
in the lecture.
But essentially, it
comes from the fact
that I'm making it propagate
in the z-direction.
What we're going
to see is that if--
whatever direction the
wave is propagating in,
my field has to be
orthogonal to it.
And we'll prove that a little
bit more carefully later.
So, for now let's just
take this as handed to us.
We can see this is at least
consistent with the properties
I've written down
here, from the fact
that it depends
on T minus z, it's
not hard to show that this thing
will satisfy the wave equation.
So we have a good source for
exploration in front of us--
excuse me-- a good
space-time for us
to explore the properties of.
So let's begin by saying great.
One of the most important
things we've learned how to do
is, given a space-time,
I can compute
how a freely falling body
moves in that space-time.
So let's consider what happens
if I have freely falling bodies
in a space-time, in a
space-time such that this--
in a space-time that is this--
so I am not saying
this very fluently.
So this is what we want to do.
We're going to consider freely
falling bodies in a space-time
that involves this h mu nu.
And the way I'm
going to do this,
my first pass is
to sort of say, OK,
I know all about the motion
of freely falling bodies
in space-time.
They are geodesics.
Geodesics describe such bodies.
So let's go ahead and look
at the geodesic equation
for this setup.
Now I wanted to--
let's give ourselves
a couple of conditions
to try and understand this.
Let's imagine that these
are-- we're initially
in a space-time that is
just flat space-time.
So we're going to imagine
that h mu nu is 0 initially.
And perhaps it then--
we're sort of imagining a
space-time in which there's
just you falling
freely in empty space.
Absolutely nothing
going on here.
And this h mu nu
field passes over you.
A wave packet passes over
your freely falling particles.
So h mu nu, not
equal 0, comes along,
and passes over your particles.
I'm going to imagine that these
bodies are initially at rest.
So when I'm in this regime
where h mu nu is equal to 0,
these guys are just sitting
stationary with respect
to whoever is making
these measurements.
So we're going to say great.
I've got these bodies
sitting at rest in what
is initially empty space-time.
A wave passes along.
What happens to these bodies?
So if these guys are at
rest, then I know that,
at initial times-- so let's
just say that this comes along,
and it becomes h mu nu not
equal to 0 at some time--
what is defined as
the origin of time.
So t equals 0 is when the
non-zero wave comes along.
So my space-time is just eta
mu nu for all earlier times.
My particles are sitting here
at rest at all earlier times,
then h mu nu comes along.
So what we want to
do, then, is look
at how does this guy
behave at t equals 0.
Now, initially, the only
component that will get picked
out of this is the 00 component.
And, working to linear
order, I can write this.
Just wanted to write
one more step in here.
Let's say that this, I'm going
to write as eta alpha beta beta
00.
Go back to your
earlier lecture, when
we defined the Christoffel
symbol to look up
the definition of this guy.
So these are all
the only components
of the space-time that enter
into this Christoffel symbol.
Every single one-- let's
go back and take a look
at the space-time that
we're looking down here.
Notice this involves
beta 0, 0 beta, and 00.
That is the space-time
parts, all of which are 0.
The other space-time
And the time-time
part, which is 0.
So the initial
acceleration is 0.
That means du alpha
d tau is equal to 0.
Which means that my particle
begins on a geodesic,
and it stays on the geodesic.
In these coordinates,
it does not move at all.
This seems to suggest that
gravitational waves have
no effect.
I have a small body here.
Gravitational waves come along.
It's unaccelerated.
So what's this for?
Well, if you think about this
for a second, what you should
convince yourself is that
the calculation I just did,
it's probably the
first one you would
think of doing
when you're trying
to ascertain how
does a body move
in a particular space-time.
But, in some ways, it was kind
of a dumb calculation to do.
So let's bear in mind,
what this is doing
is tell me the geodesic
equation describes motion
with respect to some
given coordinate system.
Satisfying this
equation is just saying,
yup, you're
following a geodesic.
And guess what?
These are-- this radiation
is a form of gravity.
Even if the body responds
to it, it is still
going to follow a geodesic.
It's going to be in free fall.
The gravitational field
may be a little bit
different from the
ones that you're
more used to from your previous
experiences with gravity,
but it is still just following
the free fall trajectory
that gravity demands.
So free fall in
these coordinates
means the body is remaining
fixed in these coordinates.
This is one of the
most important lessons
in general relativity.
When you ask a
statement that depends
on the coordinate system
you've written down,
you have to understand
your coordinates.
And I would submit
we don't really
understand the coordinates that
we wrote down here with this.
These coordinates
essentially follows the body.
Even if the body is
moving, they essentially
wiggle right along
with the body itself.
So if you want to
understand what
the impact of gravitational
waves is on things,
you have to try to
formulate what you're
able to measure using
coordinate-independent language
as much as possible.
At the very least,
you need to understand
your coordinate system a lot
better than I did in setting up
this calculation over here.
So let's reframe the
way we do this analysis.
Let's imagine-- so
one of the things
that we learned in
thinking about how
gravity works in general
relativity is I can always,
if I'm just focusing on a single
body, a single point mass,
I can always go into
freely falling coordinates.
And space-time is
essentially the space-time
of special relativity.
I can find a representation
so that everything looks just
like special
relativity near there.
Gravity is basically
completely thrown away,
at least as far as the
mathematical representation
is concerned.
I'm in free fall.
I don't really see much.
If I wanted to see the impact of
these waves, what I need to do
is think about how things
behave over some finite region.
I wanted to put together a setup
such that I have two bodies,
and the relative effect of
things between those two bodies
will allow me to see the
effect of space-time curvature
in action.
So let's now--
with this in mind,
let's consider two nearby bodies
that each follow geodesics.
So body A is right here.
And I'm going to
define body A as living
at the origin of my coordinates.
And we've got a
body B over here.
And we're going to say
that this guy is displaced
from the origin by a small
amount, some epsilon, in what I
will call the x direction.
And what I want to do is say,
OK, I've got these two guys.
They are moving
through a space-time.
Let's make this be the
space-time that we had just
discussed a moment ago.
So they are each moving on
geodesics of this space time.
We know that if I set up my
coordinate system in the way
that I've done it
here, I am not going
to see any acceleration
on each of these bodies.
Let's now try to focus on
some kind of a quantity that
tells me about the
separation between these two.
I'm going to do
this in two ways.
So the first thing
which I'm going to do
is say, let's imagine that I
am bouncing a light pulse back
and forth between A and
B. What I'm going to do
is write the 4-momentum
associated with that light.
So recall I can't really
define a 4-velocity for light
because proper time
is not defined.
But I can introduce some
kind of an affine parameter
such that d by d lambda tells me
about motion on the world line
that this light follows.
And this is just bouncing back
and forth between these two.
So it moves in the x direction.
Because this is light,
p dot T equals 0.
So these components,
the 4-momentum
associated with the light,
the dt d lambda and the dx d
lambda, they are related
to each other like so.
And look.
The space-time metric,
the gauge-invariant piece
of the space-time, hxxtt,
it is appearing in here.
So let's say, OK, what
I am interested now
is computing what--
suppose I'm sitting
at A, and I want
to compute the time,
according to A's clock,
that it takes for a pulse of
light to travel from A to B.
Maybe I'll make it bounce back.
Maybe I want to know
how much time it
takes for the light pulse to
go from A to B and back to A.
So let's turn this into an
equation for the interval dt.
So dt, I can do a little bit
of this trick called division.
Here is-- question is,
did I do it correctly?
Yes.
So I'm doing the old
physicist's trick.
I'm just imagining that
an interval of time--
an interval of
affine parameter d
lambda, the amount of
dt that accumulates
as it moves to an interval dx.
They are related by so.
And, remember, I am assuming
that the perturbation
from space-time,
from flat space-time,
is small enough that I
can always linearize.
So this can be--
I can take that square root
using the binomial expansion.
So suppose I want to
integrate up the time it takes
for the thing to go from A to
B, and then back from B to A.
Well, this is going to be
given by integrating this guy's
motion from 0 to
epsilon, like so.
And then integrating
it back again.
My tt is in here.
It's going to switch
direction when I do that,
so I'm going to flip
the sign on that dx.
I'm leaving it
written in this form,
so you have to be a
little bit careful.
You guys will play with
this a little bit more
on a problem set.
Bear in mind that as I move
through x, the time argument
of these guys is changing.
And so that's where there's
a little bit of work
that you'll explore
in a problem set.
But I'm writing it in this
form so that we get some--
naively, you might think,
ah, I'll just flip the sign
and I'll combine these.
In a certain limit, that is
indeed a good approximation.
You got to be a little bit
more careful in general though.
This is the time it
would take for light
to go from A to B and
back in the absence
of this gravitational
wave, this hxxtt.
Notice there is an
inference on the time
of arrival of these pulses
that depends on hxxtt.
Time of arrival of
the pulses depends
on this particular piece
of the space-time metric.
One could imagine, if
you had a precise clock,
and you sat there and you timed
the arrival of these things--
let's say you sent a pulse
of light out-- bloop--
and you kept track of how long
it took with a very precise
clock, you could look for-- in
the absence of a gravitational
wave, that would be, if you
imagine that your pulse was
sent out perfectly
periodically--
let's say every millisecond
or something like that,
you sent out a little pulse--
if it arrives back and your
arrival pulses were just as
spaced by 1 millisecond,
you would say, great,
I am sitting in
empty space-time.
But if you found that
their arrivals varied,
you would think, hmm, there's
something else going on here.
Gravitational waves
is one of things that
could lead to that variation.
So this, at least,
is kind of a proof--
this calculation I just did--
you guys are actually, on one
of the upcoming problems sets--
I believe it's problem--
I can't remember
if it's 7 or 8--
you do a little
analysis where you
will use this to understand
how a detector like LIGO
actually functions
to measure out
the effects due to a
gravitational wave on the arms
of a detector like this.
Let me just do one more
way of understanding
how it is the gravitational wave
leaves an imprint on these two
separated particles.
So when you look at that
first naive calculation I did,
the fact that I got
no effect, I sort of
joked that we did
a dumb calculation.
To be fair, it wasn't that dumb.
What we're-- the first thing you
usually think of doing when you
want to understand the motion
of a body in space-time,
is you look at geodesics.
Geodesics just tell me that this
guy's acceleration with respect
to the free fall frame is 0.
And that's exactly what
we ended up getting.
It's basically just saying, ah,
even in a gravitational wave,
my two bodies are
moving on geodesics.
If I have two separate
bodies, like I
have in this calculation where
I just calculated the variation
in the time of arrival
of light pulses,
one of the tools
we've learned is
that I can have two geodesics,
two free fall trajectories that
deviate from one another.
So let's look at the geodesic
deviation of the free fall
world lines of these two bodies.
So I'm going to--
as I did when I did my
geodesic calculation,
I'm going to take
them to initially
be close enough that they
have the same 4-velocity.
And if you want to be careful
about counting orders here,
you can imagine, when the
gravitation wave comes along,
that one or both of them might
pick up a correction of this
that's of order h.
Depends on what kind of
coordinate system you pick up.
But the key thing is that
they start out like this.
The gravitational
waves may come along
and it will move them
around a little bit.
But the amount it's
going to move them,
the amount of velocity that
they're going to pick up,
and the displacement
they're going
to get from their initial
position if they're at rest,
it can only be of order
of the h that you're
trying to measure there.
So I'll remind you, the
equation of deviation,
equation of geodesic
deviation, it
defines a sort of proper
acceleration acting on--
whoops, that's a typo.
It is the proper
acceleration on a vector xi
that defines, in a
precise geometric way,
the separation of two geodesics.
And what it looks like
is the Riemann curvature
of your space-time contracted on
the 4-velocity of your bodies,
and that separation vector xi.
So, linearizing
everything, bearing in mind
that R will itself
be of order h,
and that any difference
between the proper time
along these things and
the coordinate time
of a particular clock is
also going to be of order h,
they are small enough that
this equation becomes--
Something that looks like this.
Notice I'm only looking
at the spatial components
of the separation vector xi.
And that's because,
since I'm working,
since this is what my
4-velocity looks like,
I'm going to pick out the 00
components of these things.
And, don't forget,
Riemann is antisymmetric
when I exchange either indices
1 and 2 or indices 3 and 4.
And because of that, the
time-like component of this guy
is going to be an
uninteresting thing.
I will just get that is
equal to the acceleration
of the time-like component is 0.
So it doesn't really matter.
So this is telling me that
the geodesic separation
of these two world lines is--
it's a second-order
equation in time,
and it's proportional to
the separation itself.
We need to work out all
of these components.
That is a fairly
straightforward exercise,
and I will just report
to you the results.
A brief aside.
If you want to sort of verify
the results I'm about to write
out here, you could go into--
you could look up the definition
of the Riemann tensor.
Bear in mind that you are
doing things at linear orders.
You can throw away the terms
of, like, connection times
connection.
It's just derivatives of the
connection that are going
to matter at linear order.
But, even so, it's a bit
of a grotty calculation.
I am-- as I begin to reorganize
the problem sets associated
with this class
under the new system
that MIT is currently
operating on,
I will soon be releasing a
few Mathematica notebooks that
are very useful tools for
doing tedious calculations,
like computation of Riemann
curvature tensor components.
So I will put a few of
those things up there.
If you would like to
validate some of the things
that I am computing,
that is where you will
find a good way to test this.
So, anyway, the non-zero
Riemann components.
So at linear order,
you have R x0 x0.
Bear in mind that, linear order,
you are raising and lowering
indices with the metric
of flat space-time.
So that's the same
thing as this.
And this turns out to
be minus 1/2 two time
derivatives of hxx.
Y0 y0-- that's your
yo-yo component--
pretty much looks
exactly the same,
but it's two time
derivatives of the yy piece.
Remember though-- I've
erased it a while ago--
there are some constraints
that we found due to the fact
that my original h mu nu has
to be-- its spatial piece has
to be traceless.
In particular, we found
hyy was minus hxx.
So I can remove that
additional function,
and just leave things
in terms of hxx.
And our final non-zero
component looks like this.
All others are either 0
or related by a symmetry.
So notice, although I've
written down three different
complements here,
there's really only two,
because the symmetry that's--
it's not a symmetry of
Riemann, but the symmetry
associated with the
trace-free nature of hijtt
made these two
equal to each other.
So this and this are really
the only independent degrees
of freedom here.
All right.
Let's plug this into the
equation of geodesic deviation,
this guy, and see what we get.
And what we get is
an equation governing
the acceleration of the
x component of deviation.
Here it is.
Let's make a couple
of assumptions
and try to understand
what this is telling us.
So what I'm going
to do is-- let's
assume this is-- the first
assumption is necessitated
by the idea that I can
do linearized gravity.
So I'm going to assume that
these guys are all very small.
And I will imagine
that my displacement
vectors have some piece which--
basically, it's time constant.
It does not change.
And that there's a bit that will
be of order h that describes
how the separation
of my two bodies
responds to this incoming field.
So what I'm going to do, when
you go and you plug this in,
assume that this guy is constant
in time, and this one varies.
What I'm going to do is imagine
I don't just have two bodies.
Imagine I have a ring of bodies.
So suppose I have got
my coordinate axes here.
Horizontal is x, vertical
on the board is y.
And so imagine I have a
ring of bodies, like so.
And let's consider
the following limit.
Let's imagine that my
hxx is some function that
is sinusoidally varying
in time, and my hxy is 0.
I just want to call that the--
as we saw, there's
really only two degrees
of freedom in this field.
And in the way that
we formulated it,
it's going to encapsulated by
these two functions, xx and xy.
So let's just look at one.
Let's just look at the
influence of the hxx.
So when you do this,
you essentially
have the second
derivative of xi x
looks like two derivatives of
your x field, your xx field
times xi x.
And two derivatives,
your sort of acceleration
in the y direction, is
minus those two derivatives
of your field times xi y.
So what this is
going to do, if you
think about the way this is
going to act on these things,
you're going to get a sinusoidal
acceleration associated
with the displacement of
this little sea of freely
falling bodies as the
gravitational wave comes along.
And it's going to
do so in such a way
that the displacement
in the x direction
does the opposite of what the
displacement in the y direction
is doing.
So as time passes, you'll
find that-- so, initially,
let's say it stretches along
x, but then squeezes along y.
Then it's a sinusoid, so,
a quarter of a cycle later,
it's back to being a circle.
And, a quarter of a cycle
later, it stretches along y
and squeezes along x.
Let's consider the limit
now where hxx is equal to 0,
and hxy is some sinusoid.
So I start out with my circle.
Look at your
equations over here.
Think about what
they're going to do.
Now we're going to find that the
change in x and the change in y
is correlated.
So this guy stretches
it out into an ellipse
along a 45-degree line.
A quarter of a cycle later,
it's back to being a circle.
And a quarter of a cycle
later, it does the same thing
but with opposite sign.
These two fields,
my hxx and my hxy,
are what we call the
fundamental polarizations
of a gravitational wave.
Polarization states are
only defined with respect
to a particular set
of basis vectors.
So if I make my basis
vectors be this x and y,
we call this one, for reasons
that I hope are obvious,
the plus polarization.
The gravitational wave acts as
a tidal stretch and squeeze.
Notice what's going on here.
I stretch along this axis,
squeeze along this one.
A quarter of a cycle later,
I squeeze along this one,
stretch along that one.
So I get a tidal
stretch and squeeze,
where the main directions
along which the stretch
and squeeze are
happening is plus shaped
with respect to these axes.
This one is known as
the cross polarization.
You also have a tidal
stretch and squeeze,
but the lines of
force in this case
are along axes that
have an X shape.
So at the level
of 8.962, this is
all we're going to say about the
way that these things act on--
how gravitational waves act
and what their observables are.
And I deliberately chose
to wear my LIGO today,
because what LIGO does is
look for these tidal stretches
and squeezes.
And the way it does
so-- so, obviously, it's
technologically
not really feasible
to set up a ring like this.
But what we can do is sample
the ring here and here.
Actually, it's a
little bit better
to do on the plus
polarization plot.
So you make an
experimental setup that
samples the ring here and here.
And if a gravitational
wave comes along
and it's lined up right,
you see, ah, look at that.
I'm getting that
stretch and squeeze.
The way you actually measure
it out is essentially a timing
experiment, exactly like this
little calculation I did here.
You bounce light
between mirrors,
and you very carefully time
the round-trip travel time
from one mirror to the other.
And what's particularly cool
is the experimental aspect
of this.
So how does one measure
the time so precisely?
Well, you use a laser
beam as your clock.
And what's beautiful about doing
that is the way that you can
actually sort of do the
metrology at the level
necessary to get the precision
to measure your hxx's in here
is by interference.
So you can treat the
incoming laser beam
as defining your time
standard, and then
by interfering the light that
has traveled down the arm
and bounced back
with that laser beam,
basically the laws
of nature allow
you to automatically
check and see
whether there is a shift in
the time of arrival associated
with the action of the
gravitational wave.
So I imagine there will be
some questions about this.
There is a homework exercise
that allows you to sort of test
drive some of these concepts
and allows you to see
how it is that LIGO works.
It really just sort
of touches the-- it
just scratches the
surface of what
an amazing experimental
feat it is.
But it should give you a good
idea as to what goes into that.
Now, there is an
important part to all this
that we've not talked about yet.
I handed you hij.
Really, I handed you h mu nu.
The big thing that
we care about next
is, given a particular
source, how do I
compute this radiation field?
So bearing in mind
that hijtt, this
is the gauge-invariant
radiative degree
of freedom in my space-time,
how do I compute this guy?
And what I'm going to
do is borrow sort of one
of the most important lessons of
that gauge-invariant formalism.
So we need to be cautious of
the fact that, in some gauges--
for example the
Lorentz gauge, which
is so convenient for solving
the Einstein equation--
components of the metric appear
to be radiative whether they
are or they aren't.
This is a consequence
of our gauge.
But we also know only hijtt
is radiation in all gauges.
So that was what the
previous lecture was about.
As I've emphasized, it was
a slightly advanced one.
I don't expect everyone
to follow all details.
But if you can sort of grok
these two main concepts,
you're ready to now exploit
this in the following way.
What you do is,
step a, compute--
find some metric perturbation
in any convenient gauge
by any convenient method.
Once you have that,
extract hijtt.
You're done.
So that's what we're
going to do right
now in the last 20 or so minutes
of this recorded lecture.
So the way we're going
to do it is let's
take the linearized Einstein
equation in Lorentz gauge.
As we showed in--
I believe it was
two lectures ago,
the Einstein field
equations in this case
reduce to a flat
space-time wave operator
on the trace-reversed
metric perturbation,
being up to a factor
of minus 16 pi
G of the stress-energy tensor.
And this has an exact solution.
So I'll remind you
of this notation.
So this is the field at time
t and spatial location x.
x and t-- well, let's
write it like this.
t and x are my field point.
That is where I
measure my field.
x prime is my source point.
That is where I am looking
at my particular contribution
to the integral.
As we're doing this calculation,
there was a t prime,
but the radiative Green's
function turned that t prime
into this retarded time.
So what we are seeing
is that the field at t
depends upon what's going
on at the source at t
minus the interval of time
it takes for information
to propagate from x prime to x.
So what I'm going
to do is, first, I'm
going to introduce a
couple of approximations
that reflect the reality of
the conditions on which we
typically evaluate
this integral.
And then we're going to talk
about how to solve this thing,
and, given that we have now
solved it, how to project out
the gauge-invariant degrees
of freedom associated
with the radiation.
Whoops, pardon me.
Let's put this up.
So first is I introduce
this approximation.
It's worth bearing in mind that
when you are calculating this,
x minus x prime, which is
kind of like the distance
from a particular
point in the source
to where you're making
your measurement,
it is generally a lot larger
than the size of the source.
So the kind of situation
we're thinking about
is, here we are, making our
measurements at some point x
here.
Here's my source,
and here is a point x
prime inside the source.
So the thing to bear
in mind is that,
for the kind of
calculations where that--
when one is actually doing
this, x minus x prime--
well, if I think about
the kind of measurements
that LIGO is doing,
for example, that
is typically
hundreds of millions
to billions of light years.
The size of the source
itself is of order tens
to hundreds of kilometers.
Bit of a separation of length
scales there, you would say.
So what I'm going to do is
approximate the solution
of that integral, and,
for pedantic sake,
I'm going to use an
approximately equal.
What I'm going to do is
replace x minus x prime with r.
Let's just say that
this distance here
is effectively the same for
all points in the source.
I can pull that out
of the integral.
If you like, you
can refine this.
There's a more
careful expansion.
And if you've done
any electrodynamics,
you should be
familiar with this.
And it uses the fact that
1 over x minus x prime
can be expanded in
Legendre polynomials,
in a sum of Legendre
polynomials.
So if you do that, you
can introduce refinements
to what I'm about to
derive right here.
What this does, then, is it
defines a multipolar expansion.
I am not going to do that.
I'm just going to look
at the very first term.
And you can sort
of think of that
as saying that I am just
doing the leading, the most
important multipole.
Additional multipoles beyond
that are certainly important,
and people who work in the field
of gravitational radiation,
we certainly do
not neglect them.
In fact, much of
my current research
is based on sort of high-order
calculations associated
with looking at behavior of
some of those multipoles.
This will be fine for
initial pedagogical purposes.
Next, we're going to use the
fact that only the spatial--
whoops.
That's not supposed
to be an h tilde.
My apologies.
That's supposed to be
h bar, because this
is the trace-reverse thing.
Weird times, folks.
Where was I at?
Yes.
So I am only going to care about
the spatial pieces of this.
You might protest, hey,
isn't it the spatial part
of the metric, not the
trace-reverse metric,
that matters?
And you would be correct.
If you do this carefully,
to be perfectly blunt,
you have to sort of
finish the calculation
before you can kind of justify
the step I'm about to make.
And we're not going to have
time to do that very carefully,
but I'll make a
comment about it.
For now, it suffices
to say we only care
about the spatial components.
So I'm going to take my
alpha beta over to an ij.
So I now have
something that involves
the integral of
the spatial pieces
of the stress-energy
tensor over my source.
And now I'm going to take
advantage of an Easter egg
that was hidden in
an early problem set.
Back on problem
set 2, I asked you
to prove a result that I called
the tensor virial theorem.
One of the reasons why I
assigned that was that I knew I
was going to need
it in this lecture.
And what the tensor
virial theorem
told us is that if
I integrate that,
this ends up being equivalent
to 1/2 two time derivatives.
It's equal to the integral
of two time derivatives--
excuse me.
It's two time derivatives of
the integral of the 00 piece
of my stress-energy tensor.
So it's the second moment
of that, xi prime, xj prime.
This is great, because what I've
got in the left-hand side here,
that's exactly what
my integral is.
Actually, you know what?
This is going to give
me a result that's
sufficiently clean.
I want a new board.
So when that is done,
what I finally see
is that my hij,
trace reversed, is
2 G over r two time
derivatives of a tensor
that I will call Iij.
This is what I get
when I integrate T 00,
two moments of T 00.
This is called the quadrupole
moment of the source.
The asterisk is because,
as you guys will
see on one of the
problem sets, there's
a slight tweak that goes
in the exact definition
of the quadrupole
moment which has
to do with the behavior
of the trace of Iij.
I will just leave
this like so for now,
and leave you guys to explore
that on a problem set.
So we're almost done.
What I now need
to do is pull out
the transverse and
traceless piece of this.
Let's consider the
transverse condition first.
So, to do the
transverse condition,
I'm going to take
advantage of the fact that,
far from the source, box
of h bar ij is equal to 0,
because I'm in a region where
the source is equal to 0
when I'm far away from it.
This suggests that
what we ought to do
is expand our
solution plane waves.
So what I can do is write h bar.
And I'm going to choose
my indices carefully here,
call it jl.
It's some amplitude that does
not depend on space or time,
e to the i omega t minus a
wave vector dotted with x.
So this amplitude may depend
on omega, may depend on k.
It does not depend on t or on x.
And the reason I changed
my indices from i and j
to j and l, and I did
not use the index k,
is just to avoid confusion
between square root of minus 1
and the wave vector.
To be absolutely careful,
this is a single mode.
If you like, maybe you should
think about this as something
that I have--
I'm doing a sum or an
integral over omega and k
in order to reconstruct
the whole thing.
This is just a single Fourier
mode in the wave field.
So if I want this
to be transverse,
that condition is that
the divergence of this guy
be equal to 0.
But when I take the divergence
of this, this becomes--
I pull down a factor of
minus i, and I pull down
the j-th component
of my wave vector k.
And I get my wave--
my Fourier term.
That can be thought of as--
so we can clear out
the factor of minus i.
The transverse condition
boils down to saying that kj--
whoops.
No, that's right.
That's right.
kj contracted on the
wave field is equal to 0.
In other words,
the wave field is
orthogonal to the wave vector.
If you have studied
electrodynamics,
this should be familiar to you.
This is the same--
it's exactly the
same as the idea
that when I have an
electromagnetic wave,
my E field and my B field are
orthogonal to the direction
of propagation.
Let's define a unit vector n sub
j to be kj but just normalized.
So my wave is propagating in the
direction of the unit vector n.
Go back to another Easter
egg that was hidden
on an earlier problem set.
You guys studied
projection tensors.
If I introduce the
projection tensor Pij,
Pij will project
any spatial vector.
It will project out the
components normal, orthogonal
to the direction
of propagation n.
You can in fact think of
Pij as defining the metric
for the subspace that
is orthogonal to n.
So imagine that your wave is
propagating in the n direction.
There's a plane being
carried along with it.
The plane is orthogonal
to n, and Pij
is the metric you use to
define spatial distances
in that plane.
Using Pij, we can now make
my h trace-- excuse me.
I can make it transverse.
All I need to do--
I'll put one T on this
to denote Transverse.
Whoops.
All I need to do is
project each of its indices
within that tensor.
So we're almost there.
It's transverse, but
not yet trace free.
So if I take the
trace on this guy,
taking the trace on
this guy amounts to--
I am going to require
that this be equal to 0.
Now, suppose I have some
tensor that is not trace free,
and I want to remove its trace.
I'm going to make this
a two-index tensor.
So I'm not going to prove
the following result.
You can easily
verify for yourself.
The formula for doing so is that
aij trace free is aij minus 1
over N akl gkl gij.
G is the metric that
describes the manifold
in which this tensor lives.
N is its dimension.
Now, for us, the tensor field
whose trace I want to remove
is hijT.
So hij bar T is the field
whose trace I wish to remove.
This lives in the
two-dimensional manifold
whose metric is the
projection tensor Pij.
And we are working in a space
where raising and lowering
indices, there's really
no important distinction
between the two of
them, because we're
working in linearized theory.
So I remove the trace by taking
this guy and subtracting off--
pardon me just one moment.
Yes, sorry.
Subtracting off like so.
Pardon me.
It should have a T on it.
Plugging in my
various definitions,
this turns into hlk
Pli Pkj minus 1/2.
So you might want to go and
check some algebra there,
but this is all--
I'm very confident in this.
There's an overall
factor of h bar lk.
And the last thing
which I will note
is that, once I have
removed the trace,
this bar becomes meaningless.
It's trace free, so the trace
reversing of it has no action.
Now, you should be a little
bit careful about that.
There's a few different
notions of trace
that went into this definition.
Without proof, and just stating
that by being a little bit more
careful of some
of the definitions
we put down, the
difference between--
when you count this
up, you'll find
that you may be
making a small error,
but it is on the order
of terms that are
quadratic in the perturbation.
Putting all these
pieces together,
we finally obtain our
transverse and traceless
metric perturbation.
Which looks like this.
This is a result known
as the quadrupole formula
for gravitational waves.
This is-- so given--
just take a stock
of the final result.
Suppose you have some
dynamic gravitating source.
This is telling me, what I do is
I compute the quadrupole moment
associated with that source.
I take two time derivatives.
I hit it with this combination
of projection tensors, which
has to do-- that tells me
things about the geometry
of the source.
That's saying that my
source, the waves that
come from the source propagate
along a particular direction
to me.
This picks out the
components that
are transverse with
respect to that direction
and are traceless, so that I
don't have any gauge degrees
of freedom in what results.
Multiply by twice Newton's
constant, divide by distance.
And this is a wave
field that our friends
over in Building NW22 can now
measure pretty much every day.
You're going to do a few
homework exercises associated
with.
One thing which is worth
commenting on before I move on
is, when you keep
factors of c in this,
that G goes over to
G over c to the--
wait a minute.
Let me double-check that.
Is it G over c to the
fourth or G over c squared?
Anyhow, it's G divided
by c to some power.
Let's just say that it's
missing factors of c.
I may comment on
that in some notes
that I will add to the board.
And so that kind of tells
you that this is going
to be a really small quantity.
Makes it very hard for
these things to be measured.
Nonetheless, it turns out
even though they have--
if you think about the impact
they have on the detector,
even though it's small, they
carry a tremendous amount
of energy.
I'm going to take a
break before I begin
recording my next lecture.
But the next lecture
is actually going
to lead us to an understanding
of a different version
of the quadrupole formula.
It's based on this, but it
describes the energy content
of gravitational waves.
Both of these formulas go by
the name the quadrupole formula.
It's a little bit confusing
sometimes if both are used.
And you're going
to use both of them
on upcoming homework
assignments.
All right.
So I will end this
recording here.